I have two questions sure um there might
be sweet question I don't know no
question is stupid sister okay every
question is valid I have this is
something all Muslims I think talk about
I want to talk about Jin yeah I want to
ask so what Shan
yeah is he gin he's from the Gin kind so
we have different three types of
creation us human beings we are which
are created of clay or Earth second
creation is the Angels which are created
of light and uh you already you need to
take a sister was your namec Lucy Lucy
Lucy she she knows more about Islam than
I do the jins are created by from
smokeless fire I'm like she she already
knows I'm just I'm just reading her lips
and she's she she knows that smokeless
fire what's what's stopping you sister
Lucy from accepting Islam uh
honestly just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on your that you read it wherever
you was you're a muslim okay and Lucy is
a you was a I was Protestant CHR but not
like practicing not practicing on the
fence on the fence now you're a um do
you still believe in God or I do believe
in God good so you're a theist yeah okay
good so you was like me I was where you
was about 14 years ago so um I always
believed in God but I didn't have any
religion but I came to a point in my
life where I was like it doesn't make
sense for me to believe in a higher
power that's purposeless because what's
my purpose you know my glasses your
Shades have a purpose your Shades have a
purpose your dress your clothes your
socks uh this watch this microphone the
camera everything has a purpose and I
thought to myself what's my purpose you
know so that's when I started my journey
I spent about 3 years when I had that
realization looking at different
religions I started reading the Bible uh
Quran Hinduism Sikhism and I came to the
conclusion that Islam is the truth um so
yeah to to to us we as Muslims uh just
to touch up on that we don't believe uh
that God wants us to be perfect there's
no there's no Concepts that this you
have to be because the Christianity I'm
sure you was a Christian before uh you
said that for example they have this the
wages of sin is death so it's it's it's
very like you're not perfect and you
cannot stand in the presence of God
a sin exactly and that a concept alling
God create something with you are not
worthy of worshiping him if you are a
sinner never right and it's actually
very interesting because um what they do
is they obviously say is that God
commanded Adam this is biblical
perspective not as Muslims that told him
not to eat from the tree so he was he
was
um his wife Eve was they kind of to
blame her to tricken Adam and we don't
have that Concept in Islam we don't
because the reason being is because
that's one thing another thing is
because we believe that God is the most
just how can we be injust that's
Injustice in the sense where because
yeah no more please guys yeah cuz it
looks like I've gone to war and I'm
winning medals yes and these are all the
medals I've won in war yeah yes and my
t-shir is going to fall off yeah um so
the this concept also that in
Christianity that when a woman is giving
birth and she she is she the the the the
pain she gets is because of her causing
Adam to E from the tree so we say this
is nonsense because what's what's a
woman forget all any woman all of these
billions or trillions of women that
lived after Eve what's their fault let
alone EES we don't believe that it was
both of them that fell into sin and
Allah in the Quran actually um directly
questions Adam yes and Adam says look
I'm sorry I I sinned now it's very
important Islam shows us repentance
repentance was send to the world not sin
we we we the main thing that we have is
that we should have repentance so we
don't believe in this concept that's why
if you look at Christianity and many
other religions they have this um this s
Demi Gods always there's this person in
the middle that you have to go through
to God that's another thing that what
what was it that um to my my point is I
never felt comfortable calling Jesus the
son of God or Jesus being God as part of
the Trinity why
why if God is a omnipotent omniscient
Omni benevolent being then why surely
the fact that he has a son and we pray
through him it it makes him not God by
the definition of God thank you I mean
you're speaking like a Muslim I mean I
mean it's like it's like I'm hear a
Muslim preaching it's just
never you know you know what we call
that in Islam we call that the F have
you heard of it the f means the innate
disposition that you was bought with
born with because you know when you have
a phone and you change all the settings
you're like you know what erase and go
back to the factory settings what you
said that is a factory set is basically
going back to your original uh being
when you was created is what that I
don't need to come and tell you can God
have a son or is God a man you reject it
from the GetGo you're like that does not
make sense because of who God is exactly
that's why we believe every person is
born a Muslim that's why we as Muslims
say every person is born a Muslim you
know why exactly why because the thing
is you already have that internally you
didn't nobody had to tell you that you
had to be taught that God has a son and
God is Jesus but nobody has to tell you
because there was a study done in Ord
University by Justin Barrett they looked
at kids and left them like without any
outside influence of religion they all
were brought up um believing in a higher
power none of them came and said oh the
Son of God none of that so this is what
we're talking about which is the F that
you have so in Islam we say that we
don't have this thing of oh I'm dirty
I'm a sinner I can't stand in the
presence of God God says I accept you
when you speak to the Christians they're
like no no I'm like you don't understand
God accepts you the way you are the only
thing God wants is the following do not
associate Partners to him like you you
rejected you said no I believe God
doesn't have a son and that's what the
Quran says in I don't know if you like
in the
112th chapter in the Quran Allah
says say he is one yes self-sufficient
he does not beget nor is he begotten and
there is nothing like him this is who
God is to us he doesn't have a father he
doesn't have a mother he doesn't have a
daughter he doesn't have a son even
certain Pagan Arabs in Arabian Peninsula
would associate daughters as Angels they
would say oh that's God's you know
daughters yes now why because they look
down on females so they were actually
insulting gods they would ascribe Sons
to themselves and they would ascribe
daughters to God yeah as an insult not
that there's anything wrong with but
they despised females so they would
ascribe that to them and we say God
doesn't have a daughter or a son so to
us we say that all of us can stand in
the presence of God when I sin I Repent
to God I don't say oh I need to go for
Prophet Muhammad and then stop at Jesus
and maybe visit
exactly in Catholicism this is what
happens they Mary for example is they
they they don't say she's God they act
like it they say she's the mother of God
which is a mother of God so the thing is
when you go to certain Catholic churches
you'll have the statue of Mary so the
the point is that you are in directly
associating partners because if you are
saying that she has an attribute
argument sake to hear you to forgive
your sin please guys no more where am I
going to put this
put on my watch what should I do can I
give you guys some I can't carry anymore
I'm feeling the weight I'm feeling the
weight okay I'm going to hold in my hand
cuz I love you for the sake of Allah so
so the point is this is that we say that
anyone can stand in the presence of God
God doesn't want you to be perfect he
knows you're going to be Sinners and
what do we we have the evidence from the
prophet Muhammad he told us that if
mankind was not to sin so if mankind all
decided one day not to sin Allah will
destroy all of them bring forth another
nation that sins about repent so
obviously this is an example to us which
is what God is telling us I don't want
you to be sinless you are going to sin
good I just want you to turn back to me
in Repentance that's what you do with
your sin and not only that not only does
your sins get forgiven Allah turns them
into Good Deeds what that's what we
believe cuz if it's a fresh thought if
you've repented and said God I've
changed my ways God Almighty says all of
those sin that you've done argument say
um robbing people somebody was robbing
people for God how many yes obviously
there's other another um principle that
needs to apply which is to give the
rights of the people that you stole from
repenting is not just enough because if
you know who you stole from it's your
friend Islam is very careful to how you
deal with other people there's God's
rights and human beings rights God's
rights of course come first but there's
a heavy emphasis on human beings rights
which means that if I stole from my
friend and I repented I have to return
that money but if I go to him and tell
him that I stole from him it's going to
cause problems so Islam will tell us
that do it in a way where it's like you
know what bro here's a gift of £400 I
just want you to have it so you do it in
such a ways that your relationship is
not ruined you get even if you spoke ill
of someone you don't go to them and say
oh you know I spoke it of you I mean if
that person is ready to accept and say
he's forgiven but if it's someone a
grudge holder like me you know my wife
always says you're a grudge holder if
she's watching this yes yeah she's the
forgiving one I'm the grud holder I'm no
I'm yeah a grudge holder like me you'll
be like you know what it's better that
you go and give uh speak good of where
you spoke ill of him and maybe give it
charity in there it's just ways of
dealing with with that yeah but I don't
I don't give a sermon if any question
you have about Islam anything like
what's stopping you from accepting Islam
we've got someone I got sister's already
a Muslim aldah do you have you guys have
any questions I have two questions sure
um there might be stet question I don't
know no question is stupid sister okay
every question is valid I have this is
something all Muslims I can talk about I
want to talk about Jin yeah I want to
ask so what Shan
yeah is he Jin he's from the Gin kind so
we have different three types of
creation us human beings we are which
are created of clay or Earth second
creation is the Angels which are created
of light and uh you already you need to
take sister what your namec Lucy Lucy
Lucy she she knows more about Islam than
I do uh the Gins are created by from
smokeless fire she she already knows I'm
just I'm just reading her lips and she's
she she knows that smokeless fire so
she's on point aldah so smoke is fire
yeah so those are the three types of
chis that we know okay so how did like
what what happened to thean that he
became cuz he was um he was a very
righteous person yeah and then and then
Adam happened and then he wouldn't down
so so what happened is with jealousy so
jealousy is one of the root words but
it's actually jealousy is not the cause
of it so we don't believe that there is
difference of opinion on the spot we
don't believe that Satan fell into
disbelief just by not
bowing now Satan had jealousy so he was
the one when Allah tells in the Quran
that he told the angels to bow down all
them bow down except him it comes across
as if is an angel yeah that's that's it
comes across like that no we say he was
at the ranks of the Angels because the
Angels kind of do as they are told even
though we believe angels have some sort
of a free will some sort of a free will
yeah but the Angels do as they're told
yeah they can ask questions like they
did in the Quran when they ask Allah oh
Allah why are you creating the humankind
they're going to cause Bloodshed on
earth now Allah says I know what you
don't know so they can question but they
cannot disobey
so when Adam was
created El was obviously curious because
before the soul was bre breathed into
Adam was observing him like because
Allah We Believe Allah created Adam with
his own hands now in hands we say the
ways Majesty not like this yeah so we
say God Almighty created his own hand so
Adam obviously was at the ranks of the
Angels now if you have genuinely reached
that rank for the servantage of God you
would not have a problem if you're boss
or whoever decides otherwise so when
Adam was then breathed his soul into him
yes and then we believe he sneezed when
he sneezed he said alhamdulillah all
praise belong to God and then when Adam
when all the Angels including was told
to bow down to how magnificent God
Almighty has created Adam he refused now
a few things happened here number one
jealousy that he is better because what
did he say and it's actually quite
profoundly off he said I am better than
him so the first thing is number one the
fact that you're rejecting a commandment
from God is serious in itself now the
second category is him saying I am
better than him now it's very
interesting because the moment he said
that he proved what that he's not better
than him cuz if he was better than he
would exactly if he would have obeyed
what God said if you are better than him
or equal God said it I'll do it the fact
that you didn't you just prove that you
are not better than him by saying you
are better than him so that was number
one number two he ascribed a state
Allah he's basically saying to God
Almighty he's saying to Allah that you
because you misguided me he's basically
saying no it's your fault that that's
what he's saying in the Quran in the
Quran he's saying and because you
misguided me watch what I'm going to do
with them I'm going to I'm going to
misguide I'm going to do this and that
so the point is what when you come and
negate an attribute of God Almighty or
or claim or claim uh is it for them yes
you have one she's already got one she's
a quick brother she she's already she's
already armed Allah bless you for your
thing so yeah so the thing is this is
that when you ascribe a mistake to God
almighty this is a sin if I come and say
oh um god um should have not created me
like this what were you trying what you
trying to say you get it so this is
where fell into disbelief now what's
interesting is how comes Adam fell into
the same well not same sin God told him
don't eat from the tree he ate from the
tree El was told about down he didn't
what's the difference the difference is
the following is that one when he
committed the sin Adam he said it's my
fault I Repent Adam said it's your fault
you see the attitude one commits a sin
against God and says it's my fault
please forgive me I don't want to be
among the wrongdoers humbling yourself
repentance what does el do he says no
you misguided me and watch what I'm
going to do that is the attitude I have
to answer your question yeah yes so do
you have any questions for now I think
no problem I want to go back to um so a
lot of cuz you said if someone says God
created me wrong or it's like it's not
okay yeah people with low self-esteem
and depression and mental illnesses seem
to have this thing where they think God
hates them or God um not love them or
God created them uh wrong yeah how can I
talk to people about that and tell them
that God loves everyone God not cre you
wrong how does how can I give them that
belief or that mind yeah I think I think
the the statement that I made about
somebody questioning God or like not
being look somebody might not be happy
with the way their hair looks or their
nose or whatever is for that matter
these these are things that you know
we're human beings we and these are all
influenced by our um Society these are
the things that make women feel less you
know more uglier and you need to look
this and do B talks and get this done
and get that done Society has put this
pressure on woman sadly otherwise we as
human beings if we didn't have these
pressures everyone will be happy with
the way they look but there standards
that being been set that's not even real
it's actually rigged you look at these
models who are on these magazines they
don't even look the way they are in real
life because it's all photosho she can
come and say you know can you make my
stomach look this and make my this look
big whatever so the thing is that stand
so what we say is we're talking about
people who's genuinely ascribing a
mistak in the sense where like Allah is
wrong or this that and again look they
can repent if if it's coming from a
place of you know upset we all say
things that we don't mean so I'm talking
about someone who's outright arrogant
like I don't think these people fall
into it and again it goes back to them
knowing who Allah is you know if they
know who Allah is and again connecting
theel to the Quran Islam I believe Islam
is a solution to many things once they
fully immerse theirself in Islam it'll
get rid of all of this this stuff that's
what it did to me when I came to Islam
11 years ago I I I I went from societal
uh chains I was enslaved in and I had
multiple Masters not literal you know
like you know trying to trying to please
the opposite genda trying to live a
certain lifestyle working overtime
having money all this all these were my
sleaves they were Masters they I was
serving them that's what Allah tell us
in the Quran have you seen the one who
has I think say three Masters compared
to the one who has one master the
parable is what when you have one master
which is Allah God Almighty when he
tells you how what to wear how to live
you get a direct commandment now imagine
if I if there's three Masters you guys
have and I say to you I want you to jump
the other one says no I want you to sit
the other one says what you want me to
do do all three how exactly that's why
Allah gives the parable and that's how
it was with me when I was living as a
non-muslim and doing all this stuff I
realized it doesn't bring me happiness
because I'm living for others me going
like doing getting a University degree
so my family can be happy going and
doing this working over time money this
that wife so I can go it was I was just
in this Perpetual cycle of unhappiness
that's why I had to wake up and say to
myself there has to be a greater purpose
you know and I always say when I
enslaved myself to Allah is when I
became free that's when I became free
that's when I realized my true Freedom
you know why because I only care about
what Allah thinks of me I don't care
what people think Drive I don't care
what they think what I wear before they
like oh no I need to look this way and
that way or what would that they say I
don't care about you man when I die
you're not even going to come to my
grave you're probably going to speak ill
of me why should I waste the majority of
my life being upset because when I go to
my friends and say oh you know oh I
don't know I don't know what G say but
you oh your makeup looks like this or
you go to your friends and oh you know
you looks I don't care man I don't live
for you when you have that you then you
realize what freedom is about because
you free yourself from the shackle of
societal pressures and that's why I I
recommend a book called Beauty sick if
you guys bu it's from a non-muslim Offa
very good especially for females because
I believe the biggest pandemic we have
is this whole you know makeup industry
the beauty sickness because his
standards are given I mean there was a
study done that when covid happened
there was so many more woman that were
carrying on wearing the masks and they
asked him why they said well you know
what I don't have to do makeup in the
morning and I don't need to be judged by
it they were they they were not for Co
they were not scared of Co they were
like you know I'm afraid of being judged
you know you have women who are being
specifically dress wearing 5 in heels to
work and their their ankles are bleeding
why are these standards there I mean you
go clubbing and it's like minus it's
like 3 degre and you've got girls in Min
SK the point is not a woman in this
country can dress up how she like the
point is if you go to these girls and
tell them do you choose to wake up and
take 2 hours to do makeup and then your
hair and then do you choose to wear a
skirt that's going to it's freezing
outside yeah and then you're wearing
heels that make your feet believe that
you take them off and walk in bloody
pavement you know how cold pavement is
if you ask them they would think that
you know actually I don't choose to do
this I am
pressured subconsciously and I think
it's oh I love it no you don't you know
so the same applies to men as well so
these things are there and I believe
once you accept Islam you find your true
Freedom yeah what what's what's stopping
you sister Luc from accept uh honestly
other people's perspective okay would
you mean like family members or friends
or my family would be inherently against
it they just think it's so it's foreign
it is um they don't know
they it would be everyone anyone else
can do it but not my daughter that's
interesting cuz my dad like my dad is my
dad's heavily like it's not just a I
know with English people they're a bit
more if it makes you happy they have
this principle it's like if it makes you
happy yeah with my dad I don't care if
it makes you happy so with my dad my dad
was very like my dad said the thing that
I hate the most has been born into my
family I was kicked out of my house um
and I'm not saying my dad's evil my dad
sees as foreign and also he's had some
bad experience with Muslims back in our
country so I would say the following
sister look at the end of the day I
understand your family members can you
know be upset that's that's totally
normal and I think I think you're more
lucky than me you know I'm sure your
family would be a thing but again I'm
just trying to understand is there any
um questions that stopping you is this
the only
thing so then you do okay so let me ask
you a simple question do you believe God
is one yeah okay do you believe that the
Quran is from God
Almighty direct word yeah okay do you
believe the prophet Muhammad is the
final messenger from what I understand
you're okay let me put it like this you
are a Muslim let me give you an example
I'll give you an example what's your
favorite food
uh um what is it I'll tell you mine mine
is chicken and black bean sauce uh Halal
from her and for they did not sponsor
this video uh spicy noodles spicy
noodles perfect okay I want you to
repeat after me I love I love spicy
noodles spicy noodles okay now the
shahada is obviously far more greater
than this but internally you already
know you love spicy noodles you've just
told me you love spicy noodles stating
something it's stating what you already
believe that's why we say the one who
utters his he says I'm a Muslim on his
tongue but doesn't believe in his heart
is aaic it's somebody who has hypocrisy
somebody who believes it in his heart
but doesn't utter it is a disbeliever
and that's I'm talking about those who
know deep down you're not those type you
are the one that you believe in your
heart and you want to utter but
obviously there's things where you're a
little bit concerned about which is
family Etc um again look there is a
support network that we do have I would
say don't let that stop you I can't look
in the Quran in chapter Bak verse 256 it
says there's no compulsion in religion
truth is clear from falsehood so I
believe my dear sister you are a Muslim
I believe you're sincere from what I
have observed you seem like a genuine
person you seem like a nice person
that's why you have nice friends like
this you guys you know alhamdulillah so
I would say sister look it's tot up to
you but take your Shada you enough to
lose you don't need do on camera you're
not doing nothing for me we can do off
camera we can go like even if I say to
go on your way back on your way here
I'll give you a statement read it it's
not about that but I would personally
say to you take a sh you got nothing to
lose it's just a um key that you open
the door your journey starts you know
and we have ups and downs I have my ups
and downs I came to Islam 11 years ago
and I had to come to a
realization am I going to follow my
forefathers knowing that they were in
the wrong Allah says that in the Quran
are you going to follow your fathers
knowing that they were in falsehood I
couldn't do that I couldn't live with
myself knowing that because my family
members hate Islam they're hostile
towards Islam that just so they're going
to be upset of course I don't want to
upset them but let me tell you something
sister yeah Allah sometimes chooses
people like you and me to be ambassadors
to Islam because I know many people who
come to Islam they come from hostile
background the sister comes to Islam the
mother comes to Islam I know one person
have you heard ABD Rim G okay so he's
been a Muslim for about 30 plus years
his father same St didn't like it he
came from a really his dad was a banker
really wealthy family family was against
it he stuck by his guns yeah and then
his father on his death bed accepted
Islam he's got a video I'll send you the
video his father on his death bed said
the Shah and we have a Hadith about this
the Hadith says that on the on the day
of judgment a person will come in front
of God Almighty and it's so powerful
Allah they will come to God Almighty and
go God Almighty will present all of the
sins they've done and they will look
mountains like and he's like I'm I'm
going hell like this it's done and then
they will put onto the Misan the Misan
is the scale he would think is going
Hellfire God Almighty will bring a
statement and place it that will
unbalance everything and that statement
is that Shah so and that applies to a
person because when he died he was on
Muslim he had all of those sins
accumulated the only thing he has on the
day of judgment is what is the only
thing he has before he died so I would
say sister it's totally up to you you
can take a shahada with me you can take
a Shada by yourself but I would
recommend you to take
it which one would you like not on
camera perfect no problem doesn't need
to be in what we'll do is there's a
sister there I want to connect you to
but inshallah guys make Dua for sister
Lucy and um and inshah what does that
mean um
generosity okay interesting a good
friend you are your best friend yeah
good in now you guys can pray together
but you got to pray for us too course
you can't be can't be forgetting us and
the camera man you know all these people
here and I'm carrying all these mics
with me I'm joking my dear brothers and
sisters if you're watching this make Dua
for our sister Lucy and our sister Judy
J I'm bad with names I'm bad with names
some I forget my own name okay may Allah
bless you guys